uh i enjoy playing  tournaments  a lot obviously i joined them a lot more  than  i enjoyed the  um  the world championship and frankly i  don't see myself stopping as a chess  player anytime time soon  i hope to  [Music]  be able to to edge closer to one of my  other big goals which is to  to make 2900 rating  it's gonna be tough obviously um but at  the very least  i've  managed to  keep my rating  this year which  you know this  at least  it is something it means that  the goal is not further than it  than it was um  earlier although it's it's it it's tough  but we'll we'll see i'll just try and  do the right things  trust the process  and  enjoy and  frankly i'm excited to get back to  where i was  back in  2011  20  2012  start of 2013 um  where i was all set on  trying to improve  trying to be better do the right things  play the tournaments be the best in the  world  and not care about the world  championships